uh hard to believe where we are right  now better than adequate yes incredible  the whole journey has been so incredible  and to be here  it's like a miracle for us we're just  thrilled and i think we'll realize when  we wake up tomorrow morning really  what's happening next to the oscars  hopefully yeah next to the oscars when i  came here to this country  i had an oscar that i borrowed that i  put in my office and i was really  looking at it every day and saying maybe  one day i'd be lucky to get one and you  need to be patient and fight  to get where we are today one key thing  is to never give up  never give up for your dreams and always  should  aim as high as possible